I've noticed you've dropped off in terms
of like posting on Twitter and stuff
like that I have a new role with just
with Twitter which is every time I think
of something clever interesting funny
insightful to tweet instead of tweeting
it I just don't that's my rule anytime I
go to tweet just don't Tarantino maybe
you know one of the best living
filmmakers right now what does he take
like eight years to make a movie so for
like seven years you don't hear his name
he's not making IG stories to show you
where he got lunch today he's just
living his life man and his movies are
great and call me naive but I think that
it's a demonstration of where these
brilliant creatives where their focus is
and their focus is on what they do great
and I think that in social media there's
sort of this weird perversion where it's
less about your craft and it's more
about marketing yourself branding
yourself
[__] buzzword but like that's what
it's about